try of light is a 2d RPG set in a
fairytale world it's been inspired by
the watercolor art of the Golden Age
administration child of light is a
playable poem that chronicles the
journey of a young girl growing up it's
a coming-of-age story the story of child
of light follows oh haha she's a young
daughter of Austrian Duke and one day
she wakes up in the magical world of
Lemuria and her first objective is to
return home to her father during that
journey of a will meet other people
she's going to grow as a person from the
old child that needs to go home to a
young princess that always save the
kingdom of Lemuria
you know juju step in pantry enemy I'm
gonna dominant position diwali riddance
to nearest classroom from plate it's a
scary after six ebook don't see on TV
station which is damn shake the pumpkin
Genbu Edmund you like my cam accent with
a maximum lizard acquire the dune is
complacency that Johnson Space DVD Zulu
I'm sure safely drizzly gone yeah
imagine fell upon through because in his
classroom the bodies lukla isn't per
meter see this is a pampered the tuscon
when I usually do actually boutique a
Jewish was the test sampler trickle of a
yell f-word head CT Dominic listed among
head Fabian I really wanted to aim for
the fans of those classic console RPGs
people like me for example grow up a
little bit and now we have families and
the idea was can we bring those fans to
share the experience with their family
their loved ones and that's how we came
up with the idea of having the game
playable and co-op
on child of light we're using the UV art
framework engine which is the engine
developed in montpelier for rayman
origins and rayman legends the art
pipeline is fantastic the concept art is
the game art we just cut it up and it's
in the engine that afternoon it allowed
us to realize that dream of being able
to play on a living painting and see the
end of the artist in the game
just last year I only had a couple of
images an idea of what a game could be
today with the help of the thing the ID
became something really concrete and I'm
really proud of what we accomplished
when I started to think about child of
light I wanted to start working with
external collaborators in Montreal and
in our search for collaborators winded
up with people that are extremely
talented and world-renowned